[Music]
hallo YouTube just love us my friends
this is guns in here welcome to the 25th
episode of my chest strap series in this
episode I'm going to show you a
wonderful trap exist in this Resnik of
Sicilian from the back respective the
opening arises after the following order
efore c5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6 d4 C
captors d4 Knight captures d4 Knight to
f6 attacking on e4 Knight to c3
defending and now this forcing move e5
ok the mainline continues with Knight to
B Phi so trying to get the bishop pair
so accordingly blacks top this with the
moon d6 and now why it continues with
Bishop to g5 pinning down to f6 9 and in
some lines threatening Knight to c7
check black respond with a6 asking the
question to the be finite and after
Knight to a 3 and B 5 village to a
critical junction here White has two
major choices one is to play Knight to
d5 and against that I'm recommending you
should continue with Bishop to e7 and
look out the theory section however in
this episode we are going to concentrate
on the second main line which start with
Bishop captures f6
the idea is if black take with the Queen
the Knight to d5 comes with the tempo so
black has to take with the Jeep on and
as you can see I have highlighted by the
arrows very simple but effective plan of
the campaign by black he wants to play
Bishop to g7 castle on the King side and
launched with f4 f5 and a very good King
side attack
not to mention black is also threatening
the move before so something white needs
to pay attention immediately okay Knight
to d5 the obvious move that Knight is
wonderfully placed on the center of the
board but black is more than happy as he
get his counter play immediately
the moon f5 here White has tried the
various responses such as Bishop to d3
and c3 however we are going to consider
one of the most popular choice by white
and that is e captures fi and after
Bishop captures fi this tricky move
Queen to f3 so you can already see the
screen is attacking on the bishop and
the bishop cannot move because then
Knight to f6 happen on the board so
accordingly black has the only response
in this position 9:34 protecting the
bishop but the counter attacking Queen
as well
well at first sight this looks suicidal
right because here if white wish white
can grab the exchange immediately after
Knight to c7 check and if you believe it
or not but there are more than 300 games
in the database goes in this direction
where after coin capture c7 Queen
captures 8th and King to e7 white get
the exchange just within 14 moves of the
game and not only that black King is
completely misplaced so the big question
arise why black goes for this line with
the modern engine it is very surprising
that after Queen captures 8 white is
losing on the spot haha it's funny right
because doesn't look like black has any
compensation and on top his King is
misplaced but see the beauty right now
black is threatening the move b4 and
then Knight capture C to something which
white needs to pay attention immediately
and by far in all the games white
continues with c3 which is very logical
move in this position as it not only
stopped the move before by a black but
also attacking the knight
as a black if you move this night then
you are losing a quite a bit momentum so
accordingly a black has to go for this
tactics start with before hitting the a3
night and white response is false white
has to take this phone
if white foolishly take this night which
happens in few games then after B
captures a3 white is in a big big
trouble as he cannot recapture the a3
pawn and no matter whatever white plays
the best move suggested here is Bishop
captures a6 but even after this a
captures b2 attacking the rook and on
the next turn white cannot stop black to
Queens pawn the best response goes as
follows castle on the Kings side
capturing the rook with a queen rook
captures even but if you count the
material right now black is a healthy
piece up so it is very obvious that here
what has to take on b4 but after this
black has this lethal reply boom
ahahahaha so sacrificing another rogue
and their fight can take it now apart
from Bishop two at six there are many
games continue here with Queen to b6
which is another good alternative for
black but I think Bishop at six is a
direct way to finish the white on the
spot
okay White has two good choices kindly
note that Queen to defy is not a good
move the simple reason is after Bishop
to e6 white is playing like a beginner
where meantime black has developed all
of his pieces I have attached a sample
line in the PG n which will give you a
very good idea how quickly black
obtained a winning position so let's
look at the two obvious responses by
white the first move I want to consider
is
Queen captures h't which is very obvious
in this position why not grabbing the
second rook well yes you can have it
sweetie
but after Queen to be seven white can
literally pack his bag and go home
funny enough the basement resisted by
the engine here is Queen to EA check and
you can understand how bad fight
position is to understand let's see what
is the threat of black well right now
black has a simple thread Queen captures
before and that is a checkmate on D to
something which white cannot avoid
probably the best Drive I can do over
here is Bishop to c4 trying to give
escape square for the King but even
after this black can enjoy this forcing
checkmate
starting with Queen captures g2
attacking the rook rook to a fun
quint we for check King to Devin
Queen to f3 check black King has the
only Square King to even but after this
can you guess the finishing knot yup
and start with Bishop to d3 and Queen to
e2 is unavoidable as after Bishop
captures d3 Queen captures d3 the King
death is on the next turn so it is very
clear that white cannot even touch that
rook so that means what has the only
response left Queen captures a six well
after that black has another good move
in this position Bishop to c8 keep
harassing White Queen in this line what
black is aiming is he wants this Queen
either on a four or a five square so
that he can put his Queen on b7 and that
way the resulting position is quite
favorable for the black well it doesn't
matter whether Queen goes to the aid as
after Queen to b6
as the black is attacking on before
white is forced to play either queen 2 a
4 or a 5 square let's say Queen to e5
and after that we achieve our target
Queen to be 7 so Queen to e4 is a very
deadly threat something which white
needs to prevent immediately he cannot
play Bishop to d3 as G to pawn Hanks so
accordingly
what has the only response f3 but after
this black has this sneaky move Bishop
to e6 threatening rook to e8 and
trapping the Queen and it doesn't matter
whether white continues with Queen to f4
B Phi or Bishop to e6 it all leads to
the same disaster which is going to
happen very soon I like to show you one
entertaining game between two FM's where
white continues with Bishop to e6 which
is probably the best move in this
position not only white is hitting the
Queen but all set to castle on the King
side so obviously black doesn't give
this time and he plays this thematic
sacrifice yup you guessed it Knight
captures f3 check if King goes to either
f2 add even then Queen to e7 is a very
strong reply so in the game white
continues wait G captures f3 and after
Queen captures f3 black is attacking the
rook and trying to regain his space ok
white first give this jack hoping for
King to f6 so that he can play rook to a
fun but black calmly play Bishop to d7
blocking the check and now white move
the rook out of the firing line with
rook to G even so at first sight it
looks like White has saved all the
threats but because White King is wide
open
there is always chance to check meet him
very quickly in the game black played
the correct move Queen to e4 chat
and now black has to decide which
direction his King is going
if King to d1 then look to see it is a
very strong reply so accordingly white
choose the MU King to have fun but even
after this move he is not out of the
world as black has a very strong reply
Bishop to e3 threatening a checkmate
stocking with Quint where three so white
needs to stop it with rook to g3 but
this simply allowed black bean to goes
on the back rank and after the following
sequence Queen check King to e2 Queen
captures a to check King captures III
Queen captures g3 check King to e2 Queen
s to check King to e3 and now the star
mu Luke to g8 and even though white has
an extra piece look at this three guy
throughout the game they are just
sleeping while on the other side his
skin has been hunt down the checkmate
happens on the board very quickly white
plays rook to her phone losing moon as
after rook to g3 check rook to f3 Queen
check King to e2 rook to g2 check King
to d3 and now the finishing knockout
punch
yup is Queen to d4 checkmating White
King
last but not least what happens if the
Queen goes to the a Foursquare directly
well more or less same story as black is
going to continue with Queen - b7
threatening Queen check and after the
obvious response f3 the thematic Peyton
Knight to f3 check G captures f3 Queen
captures f3 attacking the rook rook to
Jeevan only move but this time around
Black has
Queen - III check and as the bishop on
f1
King can no longer protect the rock so
by force he has to play Bishop to e2
what can grab his material with Queen
captains even check bishop to have fun
Queen to e3 check Bishop to e2 and now
once again the finishing not the amazing
rook to GH and there is no stopping on
the g1 square that's it guys I hope you
enjoy and learn this wonderful trap in
one of the main line of sveshnikov
sicilian remember if you upon continue
with Queen to f3 then play the move
Knight to d4 allow him to grab the
exchange in the opening but once white
took this route and you play King to e7
even though the position looks funny for
the black in all the variations
it is only black who is coming out on
the top well thank you for watching this
video feel free to like subscribe and
comment on this and I'll meet you in my
next episode very soon bye and take care